nos preguntan cuál es la constante de
proporcionalidad entre jay y x en la
gráfica y sólo como un recordatorio
cuando hablamos de la constante de
proporcionalidad suena algo muy
complicado pero no lo es si pensamos en
cualquier parte xy sobre esta línea por
ejemplo aquí tenemos x que sigue es
proporcional a x entonces podemos decir
que que es igual a una constante por x y
esta constante es nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad y si dividimos ambos
lados entre x muchas veces verán esto
escrito como y entre x es igual a la
constante de proporcionalidad y nos
muestra que para cualquier par xy si
tomamos ye entre x eso será igual a la
constante entonces ahora que ya
recordamos eso veamos si podemos
contestar la pregunta cuál es la
constante de proporcionalidad entre sí y
x
en la gráfica bueno claramente aquí nos
están dando un punto y este punto se
encuentra en 32 entonces podemos decir
que sí que es igual a 2 y x es igual a 3
el número 2 debe de ser igual a una
constante de proporcionalidad por 3 si
queremos despejar esto simplemente
dividimos ambos lados entre 3 y así nos
queda que nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad es igual a dos tercios
otra forma de resolverlo sería con esto
porque aquí ya despejamos la constante
de proporcionalidad entonces cuando x es
3 y es igual a 2 y miren en cualquiera
de los dos casos nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad es dos tercios hagamos
otro ejemplo aquí nos dice que recta
tiene una constante de proporcionalidad
entre ye y x de 5 entre 4 pausa en el
vídeo y vean si pueden resolverlo
aquí la clave es que tenemos que probar
algunos puntos sobre estas rectas
tenemos que probar pares de equis y
decir bueno si tenemos nuestra ye y la
dividimos entre x obtenemos cinco
cuartos porque esa es nuestra constante
de proporcionalidad y entonces
analicemos la recta a sobre la recta a
déjenme encontrar el punto que nos
interesa aquí tenemos el punto que
podría ser y si tomamos este punto que
es 2,5 si dividimos y entre x
obtendremos una constante de
proporcionalidad igual a 5 medios por lo
tanto a no es nuestra respuesta nosotros
necesitamos una constante de
proporcionalidad igual a 5 cuartos ok
ahora intentemos con b vamos a ver aquí
tenemos nuestro punto sobre la recta b y
corresponde al punto 45 así que en esta
situación acá es igual a que en este
caso es sí
/ x que es 4 por lo tanto ve es nuestra
respuesta y bueno por si acaso también
podemos analizar la constante de
proporcionalidad de esta recta pero hay
un ejemplo muy interesante que me
gustaría mencionar antes de terminar
estos ejemplos qué pasa en la situación
en donde ya es igual a x cuál es la
constante de proporcionalidad en este
caso como se verá en una recta pausa en
el vídeo y piénsenlo un poco bueno no es
nada nuevo sólo que tal vez no ven la
constante de proporcionalidad cuando
vemos la ecuación expresada de esta
manera pero igual a x es lo mismo que
igual a 1 por x por eso es que para este
caso la constante de proporcionalidad es
uno o si dividimos entre x es decir si
dividimos ambos lados entre x de este
lado nos queda la constante de
proporcionalidad que es igual a 1 y si
quisiéramos graficar la severa
así que es igual a equis para todos los
valores de x por eso es que cuando
nuestra constante de proporcionalidad es
igual a 1 eso representa todos los
puntos de esta línea anaranjada que he
construido nos vemos en otro vídeo